first up for the second time in living
memory there is an election recount
crisis in the state of Florida tonight
just last week as you'll remember
Republicans Rick Scott and Ron de santis
defeated Democrats bill Nelson and
Andrew Gilliam in the Senate and
gubernatorial races there the results
seem to be conclusive at the time they
were reported on this and every other
news channel on election night last
Tuesday and yet just six days later it
is very possible that both those
Democrats will win the seats the ones
that just the other day they had lost
how did that happen exactly well
thousands of new and uncounted ballots
appeared in Florida mostly in
democratic-leaning counties and those
ballots changed the results sufficiently
to trigger a statewide recount that
recount is underway right now the
process so far is not inspiring
confidence in the system President Trump
has complained about it as have plenty
of other people including some
journalists and Senator Marco Rubio of
Florida but it turns out that
complaining about this is not allowed so
to restate the rules in case you've
forgotten when a Republican wins an
election it is fine to question the
legitimacy of the process Democrats have
been doing that since the very day Trump
was elected two years ago that is
patriotic it's your duty but when the
Democratic Party's power is at stake
raising any question at all about the
process is wrong indeed it's nothing
less than the road to dictatorship watch
he's basically trying to undermine at
every turn it's not just Florida he
weighed in on Arizona he's waiting on
other races he's undermining the
legitimacy of elections where he doesn't
like the result where where he doesn't
like the results and that is a hallmark
of a failing democracy of someone moving
towards an authoritarian he's
authoritarian scream the authoritarians
meanwhile defending the results of
elections that have already been called
is now the same as overturning elections
listen to incoming House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi explain how this works president
has been saying that there's election
fraud in Florida what do you think is
happening in in Broward County my
experience with the
president is anytime he charges somebody
with something he's just projecting what
he might have done himself we are not an
election fraud
well obstruction a suppression of the
vote
suppression Nancy Pelosi did not use
that word accidentally the term is meant
to evoke images of a darker time in
American history a time of night riders
and burning crosses a time very few of
living Americans remember personally but
that lives in our collective memory this
kind of talk can be politically useful
that's why they do it that's why it's a
theme on the left in case you haven't
noticed in Broward County for example
ballot counting is overseen by a woman
called Brenda Snipes Snipes was
previously caught illegally destroying
ballots this time around she's
apparently mixed invalid provisional
ballots with valid ones that sounds bad
but don't dare criticize Snipes for the
way she does her job
according to MSNBC the only relevant
fact about Brenda Snipes
is the color of her skin watch here is
the way they are treating Brenda Snipes
who was the longtime election supervisor
there who by the way is an older black
woman in the deep south okay just keep
that in mind as you watch this video if
you look at the person in this case a
woman involved she has had a horrible
history so in case you're wondering what
demagoguery looks like you just saw it
but why now why are they doing this now
Democrats are acting like they've been
robbed of power somehow and yet in
elections just last week that all of us
saw Democrats gained power they retook
the House of Representatives after eight
years they added several governorships
they nearly broke even in the Senate
that was not enough though they want
more and they will use any means
necessary to get it in Palm Beach County
the county canvassing board disqualified
a vote because it was cast by a non
citizen non-citizens are not allowed to
vote in federal elections it is illegal
it also never happens in this country
ever
we're told that again and again and
anyone who disagrees is racist but in
this case actually did happen nobody
disputes that
the Democrats response to this happening
attorneys for Gilliam and Nelson said
the vote should not be disqualified they
objected to the disqualification because
the only thing that matters to them in
the end is winning it's easy to find
yourself thinking like this if you
believe politics is holy war - a
religious extremist an election is not a
contest between fellow Americans who
disagree on policy it's an existential
battle between good and evil evil must
be vanquished at all costs no matter
what Christian Gillibrand has reached
this conclusion now senator Gillibrand
is not an obvious candidate for
America's leading moral voice she was a
longtime friend and defender of Harvey
Weinstein's for example but listen to
her now preaching like it's the last
Sunday in Lent are you staying in the
Senate or are you gonna run for
president I've been thinking about it
because as we said earlier what
President Trump has been putting into
this country is so disturbing so
divisive so dark that I believe that
I've been called to fight as hard as I
possibly can to restore that moral
integrity that moral decency thinking
about it moral integrity moral decency
that's what Democrats are telling you
they are defending and if you think
about it for a minute that is worrisome
people who know how deeply flawed they
are tend not to overreach they have
humility but when you're a holy warrior
on a mission from God what won't you do